desantis right now is calling for a new
kind of law
that would allow doctors who trans
little kids
to be sued
these very young kids getting
gender affirming care they don't tell
you what that is is they're actually
giving very young girls double
mastectomies they want to castrate these
young boys that's wrong and so we've
stood up and said both from the health
and children well-being perspective you
know you don't disfigure
10 12 13 year old kids
based on gender dysphoria 80 of it
resolves anyways by the time they get
older so why would you be doing this i
think these doctors need to get sued for
what's happening i'm sorry they
absolutely do so this is a good line for
desantis he's also testing out now this
idea he's
he's saying hey what do you think if we
made it such that you could sue doctors
for transiting the kids and it's getting
some applause they'll see how it plays
in the local press and then i hope
governor desantis will actually turn
this idea into a law
and what the libs and the technocrats
are going to say is excuse me governor
desantis where's your medical degree you
don't even have a lab coat or a
stethoscope you're not even a genius
medical physician like dr rachel levine
or dr fauci or you know all these people
who are just completely insane and wrong
about everything you're not even one of
those medical doctors you're right
you're right should be desantis's answer
you're right i'm not a medical doctor i
don't have a medical degree and you know
what i don't need one
i'm the governor
and that when we're talking about
political matters and the law and
government and how we run our society
and how we treat poor little kids who
are being victimized by creeps and
perverts
being a governor is much more important
than being some stupid medical doctor
working for the public health
establishment transiting the kids and
killing the babies and locking us all
down for two years that's the answer
oh yeah okay you've got your
statistics and your studies and okay
that's fine
by the way all of the actual credible
studies on on these sorts of issues are
on our side there is no credible medical
study that says that boys are actually
secretly girls that doesn't exist
okay so the the libs are
are though they claim the mantle of
science are obviously very unscientific
but that's actually beside the point we
live in self-government and the people
of florida have the right to say don't
trans the kids i don't care what your
stupid medical doctors and your
establishment says it doesn't doesn't
matter to me we're not going to let you
trans the kids and if you try to do it
we're going to sue you and ideally we
would throw you in jail or banish you to
saint helena along with dr fauci and all
the rest of you power mad technocrats
that's the right answer
and we and you can have the scientific
conversation too
you can have the scientific conversation
and say well actually you see the girl
has the two x chromosomes and the boy is
the xy chromosome and actually if you
put the kids on puberty blockers too
early then that's going to give them
osteoporosis and actually it's going to
give them and it's going to sterilize
them that's true that's all true it's
all it's all pertinent
but those are secondary matters
the first most important aspect here is
our liberty not the individual liberty
to mutilate yourself or to mutilate your
kid even
the higher political liberty to say this
is the kind of society we want to live
in
we're going to have a normal definition
of man and a normal definition of woman
and we're not going to let perverts and
radicals
castrate our children and that's that
and you can whine about it and you can
cry about it if you don't like it move
to california but we're not doing it in
florida
if and desantis obviously gets this he's
testing the waters i think if he goes
all the way on that kind of message
it's going to serve him very very well
in a 2024 presidential election if he
indeed runs for president right now head
on over to goodranchers.com knowles i
love good ranchers because the food is
absolutely delicious and it's american
beef and it's just magnificent i eat it
probably three times a week but in
addition to that the second reason i
love these guys
is they're really good guys back to
school season is upon us while many
american kids are excited to get back
into the classroom some others are not
because these children don't know where
their meals will be coming from this
semester
that's why good ranchers has made it
their mission to donate 100 000 high
quality meals to kids facing food
insecurity and malnourishment this fall
semester for every box ordered through
the month of august
good ranchers will donate a nutritious
meal to a child in need help them reach
their goal of one hundred thousand
donated meals by ordering your box today
goodranchers.com
knowles they are an award-winning food
delivery service ships hundred percent
american meat and seafood right to your
door
they were just named the best food
subscription service earlier this year i
totally agree with that they are the
fastest growing meat company in america
the quality is off the charts right now
use my code knowles to get thirty
dollars off your order plus free
shipping your purchase furthers their
mission to donate a hundred thousand
high quality meals to children in need
great cause that everyone should rally
behind goodranchers.com knowles head on
over use code knowles today when you
place your order and let's get these
guys some help to hit their goal there
is a little bit of bad news just came
out of kansas we had
one of the election days we have a
number of election days this year
because it's a midterm election year
different states hold different
primaries and elections on different
days we had a little bit of a
disappointment in kansas there was a
pro-life amendment
that was put up as a referendum the
people were voting on this amendment and
the pro-life amendment failed and
there's some lessons here for pro-life
activists conservatives more broadly
into why it failed and how we can avoid
failure in the future
so the pro-life amendment in kansas
was the first
statewide referendum on abortion since
the dobbs decision came down and
overruled roe v wade and overruled
planned parenthood v casey and got rid
of the
national constitutional right to an
abortion that doesn't actually exist
the the referendum was a little bit
weird the kansas state constitution
includes a right to abortion
the
referendum that just failed was to
replace the
pro-abortion amendment the right to an
abortion in the state constitution with
a right to life
so a a constitutional ban on abortion in
kansas and it failed
unfortunately it failed
by 17 percentage points so it was not
particularly close
and
uh the question is why did it fail how
did it feel i don't know i don't have
the text of the amendment in front of me
uh
the the
title of the the amendment was the value
them both amendment
but
the issue of abortion is not simply
black and white
there can be nuance here and don't
forget we're called to be
wise as serpents and innocent as doves
so one way that the pro-life amendment
perhaps could have been framed
is
not even as a pro-life amendment but as
a get this crazy abortion thing out of
our state constitution amendment in fact
the way that
you just saw the pro-life issue play out
at the supreme court the supreme court
didn't come down and say okay now we
have a national right to life the
supreme court came down and said it's
not in the constitution make your own
laws
had this been more of a legislative
matter rather than a referendum for an
amendment to the constitution
that might have worked out a little bit
better for pro-lifers or it's hard to
tell with kansas
we're going to see how this play
generally you think of kansas as a
fairly republican state fairly
conservative place we will see how this
plays out throughout the rest of the
country but it's an important reminder
because i think conservatives are
feeling a little uh
a little like the wind is at our sales
right now and in many ways it is but
it's not going to be a simple
victory after victory after victory
after victory we're gonna have to be
clever we're gonna have to tailor our
message to different states we're gonna
have to
know that what works in virginia is not
gonna work necessarily in texas it's not
gonna work necessarily in florida is not
going to work necessarily in kansas
we've got to be clever and take the the
greatest wins that we can possibly get
without letting perfect get in the way
of good
i'm so glad you like that clip you know
we hit 1 million subscribers and that's
big i know but we don't want to rest on
our laurels we don't want to pet
ourselves on the back i want to hit 1
billion i do so i really need you to
ring subscribe like click
myspace i don't know make sure you get
the notifications we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]